alright 2019 what you got for us so
started the new year and there's a
couple things I like to do at least
since last year I think last year was
the first time I did them I in in any
case I think this this list I've been
doing a few years more than that the one
that'll come out a little bit later
that's a more recent thing but in any
case I want to talk about the movies
coming out in 2019 that I am personally
most excited for now I want to be clear
about this list firstly these are not
the only movies that I think will be any
good they're the ones that I am
personally the most excited to see and
also I try and limit this list stuff
that I'm genuinely excited about as
opposed to merely hopeful for because
honestly I'm hopeful for most movies
that I think I want to see I want them
to be good but that doesn't mean that
I'm necessarily pumped at this point so
let's take a look at what we got oh I'm
also doing the list a little bit
differently normally I've done it like a
ten to one getting to my most excited
I'm not gonna do that this time cuz I
had a really hard time trying to order
these out so instead I'm just gonna go
through them chronologically in the
order that they are coming out this year
so we'll start at the first one coming
out this year that I am excited about
and that is glass what a weird world we
live in that I'm now actively excited
for him like shot M night Shyamalan
movie boy it's a crazy time to be alive
isn't it I really like split split was
quite good and quite enjoyable and James
McAvoy nailed it and realizing its
connections to unbreakable which is also
a very good film and having this title
glass and like knowing that it's gonna
have a big focus on the the Samuel
Jackson character oh man I'm really
excited for this and I'm just I'm hoping
I am crossing my fingers that they
didn't grant
that they didn't give Shyamalan too much
money cuz I feel like in a lot of ways
he does his best work when somewhat
restricted when he can't just do
anything because the times that he
played with the most money and had the
most you know resources to expend that's
usually when he gave up he did the worst
product so I'm just I'm hoping oh boy
if this pulls together though it's gonna
be something amazing and that first
trailer yeah I'm hopeful and I think I
think it's gonna be really good okay so
next one coming out after that is going
to be the lego movie to the second part
and yeah the lego franchise has been
really really good I mean the lego movie
was great in my personal opinion like a
Batman was even better and lego ninjago
was the most disposable but it was still
really solid so when the worst thing
that you put out was a pretty good like
that that gives me reason to be hopeful
especially if you're going back to one
of the ones that was really good I'm
excited to see a lot of these characters
again I'm excited for unikitty and for
Emmet and for Lucy and and to see all
these these characters again I love this
animation style I love the the pace and
the speed of it while still holding on
to a really firm central theme and
through line so that it's not just
bombard the joke the jokes don't bury
the theming these things have been
really well constructed and I'm looking
forward to the next one okay so the one
I've got to talk about after that is a
little bit weird and probably has it's
one of two films that has kind of the
most tenuous place on this list in that
I can kind of see the ways that it might
go wrong but I kind of can't help but be
excited anyway and that is Aleta battle
angel now I've got a couple things going
for me here one is that I while he is
very hit-or-miss when Robert Rodriguez
is good he's really good and I feel like
this material would be a good fit for
him and I do have a love for the
material III
I like the manga I like
the the Oh a V that was done previously
I love this cast I'm really excited for
it and I'm also kind of intrigued by the
fact that some things have already been
tweaked based off initial responses so
there was the deal made about you know
the eyes for the lead character and when
people were kind of off put by them
Rodriguez tweaked them not making them
smaller but making the irises bigger so
that it took up more of the eyeball
wasn't so much white space but I I like
that he didn't just dig his heels and go
well this is what I've decided to do I'm
gonna do it he put something out he's
like oh they didn't react the way I
wanted let me tweak it and now people
seem to be taking better to it and I
appreciate like I can respect somebody
who holds their ground on artistic
stance but I also really appreciate
somebody whose primary goal is to be as
entertaining as possible and if it's not
getting the response he wants from the
audience he'll tweak it so yeah knowing
that James Cameron is the guy to hand on
this and really getting the feeling that
this is something Rodriguez is
passionate about yeah I'm still hopeful
all right after that we have a film I've
been waiting a long time for and I'm
gonna be really sad to see at the same
time and that is how to train your
dragon' the hidden world now
I didn't love the trailer not because
what was in it didn't look good but
because it looks like DreamWorks has
done the exact same thing they did with
How to Train Your Dragon 2 which was to
give away the major plot twists from act
2 yeah so setting that aside this
franchise has just earned so much
benefit that out for me
that first one was its it swept me off
my feet it caught me completely off
guard with how go to what I saw it on a
whim and then the second one was my
favorite film of that year and it I
really do love these movies I love I've
loved the progression from the first of
the second the way it grew the way the
characters grew the way the themes grew
and I'm really interested to see what
they're going to do especially knowing
that this is a very
intended to be the final one in the
series and is gonna be addressing why
dragons aren't still around so I think
it has a potential to be very
bittersweet and very sad in a good way
all right next up the other one that's
got a slightly more tenuous place on
this list priced I'm still excited for
and that's Captain Marvel and I know the
the trailers have been oddly divisive I
still like what I see for the most part
I really like this character I think
brie Larson is a pretty good fit for it
I'm excited for more Samuel Jackson
because it's more Samuel Jackson why
would I not be excited for that and the
visual aesthetic that I've seen so far I
liked and I'm like I said they'd like I
still feel like it belongs on this list
but this is probably the least woo of my
Woo's that I have you know did about
these movies but again a bit like How to
Train Your Dragon the Marvel films have
earned a lot of goodwill for me am I
automatically gonna like it no matter
what
well no I didn't really like a man the
loss of that much when I saw it and I've
come to like it even less uh-huh the
more I've thought about it since but
they earn a significant benefit of the
doubt going in and I see enough stuff
that excites me that yeah I'm excited
next one after that was one that I
actually didn't have on the list but
then the trailer dropped the only reason
it wasn't on my list before was because
I didn't know enough about it but us
this is Jordan peels follow-up to get
out which was my favorite film the year
that that was released and god this
looks nuts and I'm excited for now it
looks weird and trippy and surreal and
possibly you know metaphorical and I
just I want to know what's going on I
want to see how this plays out I want I
want to I want to sit down for days
afterwards and parse out how everything
links together on what it means and I oh
god if you haven't seen this trailer see
this trailer because this
nothing that I could say that would make
any sense or land with a kind of impact
the trailer has if you haven't seen it
go see it if you like horror I hope
you're excited as excited for this movie
as I am alright after that we've got the
Marvel film that is by far the one I'm
more excited about and that is Avengers
endgame so yeah as much as Marvel itself
as a sort of property and brand has
earned my goodwill the Avengers
franchise specifically and the Russo
brothers in particular who are directing
it have absolutely earned a lot of
goodwill so like here's what the Marvel
goodwill gets on its own here's what the
Russo brothers get for their work on
Marvel's so uh yeah I'm super excited
about this trailer was awesome I'm I'm
just really really really pumped I loved
infinity war I thought it was terrific
and I cannot wait to see how this sort
of era really comes to a close and a bit
like How to Train Your Dragon 3 I'm it's
it's gonna be a little bit sad but oh
it's gonna hurt so good and I want it
following that we've got another one
that made it on thanks to a trailer it
was one that I was hopeful intrigued
about up to this then the trailer
dropped in like yeah many black
international so I'd said it why I did
my review of the trailer this is the
sequel to men in black
I have literally always wanted I always
hated how men in black 2 did not pick up
the baton from the very obvious set up
at the end of the first men in black
which is that J has a new partner
why are we cruel barring the the plot
into these weird into this weird bizarre
thing that doesn't work just to get
Tommy Lee Jones back like it uh enough
about that but this this is what I
always felt it should have been you
continue to focus on the agency but you
start focusing on other elements other
agents in other locations other than
just New York and this is doing exactly
what I always wanted this franchise to
do and it's got great actors besides
it's got Liam Neeson and Emma
and Tessa Thompson and Chris Hemsworth
them yeah yeah I want it so after that
we get to one that there is not a
trailer for at least at the time of
recording my luck the trailer will drop
between when I record this and when I
release it we'll see spider-man far from
home and since there isn't a trailer
this one is based solely off of how much
I love spider-man homecoming because I
like spider-man homecoming a lot I love
Tom Holland as as Peter Parker I love
the way that his youthfulness was
handled which is odd for me because I've
kind of been clamoring for an older
Peter rather than going back to the
teenage Peter every single dang reboot
but he's super endearing and I really
really enjoy him and I like the themes
that are used especially within the
context of the greater I'm see you
it had terrific villain and while
Mysterio is far from my favorite Jake
Gyllenhaal's a good actor so yeah show
me what you got Spidey and finally the
last one on here is like this one's got
to be completely random and it's
literally just because I really liked
the book when I was young and that's
called wild which is a book about a dog
[Laughter]
you know they in in a snowy setting and
there's you know some grumbling humans
and he has to climb it himself to the to
the pack and I just I always really
liked the book and the movies gonna have
Harrison Ford it's just yeah there are
some things that I just liked as a kid
that I I just like seeing I feel the
same way about Treasure Island and I
have a really soft spot for any vert any
film version of Treasure Island for a
similar reason I think it just kind of
taps in to that sense of adventure
that I really enjoyed from these kinds
of books when I was a kid so yeah for
that reason alone I mix I'm excited for
a movie that has no
is coming out in December yeah there you
go
random addition at the end but those are
my 10 films that I am the most excited
for going into 2019 what about you what
are you really excited about keep this
one positive there'll be a separate
video about the ones we don't think will
be any good so save those comments for
that one but whatever your thoughts are
whatever ones you're looking forward to
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
you can do because it's buttons and
links and there's a link to my patreon
if you feel like supporting me and this
type of content it would be greatly
appreciated there's also a fit like you
should check out if you want to do that
don't want to do that that's ok too
because at the end of the day you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]